so you think to vote and his wife are
super villains who are you really
I was born on the city even in your word
every question ever asked the body is
deteriorating faster than the chair can
handle ok survive Lauren
I'm being framed for something that I
didn't do he stood among awesome
wolf sheep's clothing this is the only
way tell everyone you're the flash if
every one of my secret we would never be
able to stop robbing happy holidays
everyone there's a whole bunch of DCTV
that just dropped so I figured I'd do a
video I know a lot of you been
requesting young justice so that's also
part of this - there's also a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber and
leave a DC related comment on the video
so we'll start with the flash stuff then
I'll talk about Legion of super-heroes
Brainiac introduction then I'll talk
about Batman Beyond on Young Justice we
got a little more information about how
the trial the flash is gonna play out
because like the trailer lets you know
he tries to be the flash while this is
going on and it totally doesn't work we
know he trades the flash costume for
that prison jumpsuit and iron Heights so
he can't be the flash and be sitting in
prison at the same time without breaking
the law
sure he could phase right through the
wall no big deal but he'd have to blur
his face continually to keep cameras and
people from recognizing him but the
synopsis for the episode teases that
iris and Jo must decide how far they're
willing to go to keep Barry out of
prison meaning that Jo is probably going
to cross the line like he was ready to
kill Devo sitting in his chair in his
house as an intruder if it meant
rescuing Barry so earlier this season
they teased the idea of Joe crossing the
line you may remember me talking about
that before episode 7 because that was
when they laid all the cards on the
table before that the producers had
teased that Joe would have his own
battle with a thinker that would be
different from Barry so Barry has a
little more of a literal fight like he
fights the villains each season Joe
versus the thinker is more of him being
backed into a corner where he's willing
to doctor evidence to get Barry off
because they can't do it the legit way
but I don't think that they're gonna
turn Joe into a criminal just to get
Barry off so they'll take him right to
that line he'll probably struggle with
that idea but let me know in the
comments how crazy do you think that Joe
is going to go trying to protect Cecile
and his future baby along with his other
child Barry but I think we're all just
wondering when Cecile's baby is going to
become relevant to the thinker story arc
because right now it's like you have all
this thinker stuff going on the trial of
the flash Barry's been framed and then
you've also have Cecile who's pregnant
with a bay
she has been in no way threatened by the
thinker he hasn't made any comments to
Joe that lets us know that he knows
Cecile is pregnant so right now those
are like two completely unrelated things
by the end of the season they had to
bring those together we're gonna need
more diapers the big thing with legion
of super-heroes a lot of you may have
started watching Supergirl since they
started teasing this storyline maybe
you're not watching but you're just
curious about the Legion what's
happening in the next episode of
Supergirl is that they're introducing
Brainiac 5 which is a pretty big deal
they did a version of him play by James
Marsters on Smallville he's gonna help
rescue Supergirl who rain beat into a
coma in the midseason finale so he
didn't see it Supergirl got her ass beat
so that's why they need to roll Brainiac
out so presumably he'll be on for the
rest of the season and he might wind up
being a love interest because this is
what the actor looks like itll love
triangles or kind of the thing that they
do on Supergirl
so we'll see who the next Legion
character they introduced after Brainiac
is but right now they already have three
including Mon L they haven't said what
his backstory is going to be on the TV
show because it various times they've
retcon things so originally he was
descended from Brainiac
- so Brainiac was sort of like his
grandfather in a sense but then later
more recently as the new 52 he's more of
a clone of Brainiac 1 the evil version
of Brainiac so we the way he winds up
working with the Legion of super-heroes
he has super intellect and that he's
sort of a human calculator compared to
the other peoples of the 31st century
remember that bunny reverse-flash line
where he says in the future I'm a genius
how smart do you think that makes me
here it's the same thing for Brainiac 5
but he develops this special computer
called computo they might work up to
that on the TV show but he also creates
a time sphere that he uses for time
travel that might be how they wind up
getting the Legion back to the future
when they eventually leave Supergirl
because I don't think they're gonna stay
on the show for forever but whatever
they end up doing I'll do an easter egg
video for it so no worries so getting
into Batman Beyond I know you're all
wondering about Young Justice season 3
stuff when's it going to drop when are
we going to see a trailer the producers
have been very active on social media
answering fans questions and also
teasing them like oh you know maybe
we're gonna do this so people are asking
about characters that they might be able
to do in the future the question of
Terry McGinnis Batman Beyond came up
like would he cameo
[Music]
sorry pal but you're history who sent
that thing it didn't say whoever it was
they didn't stop it one
[Music]
seven against two pretty bad odds in the
producers were like yeah we could
totally do that you just have to watch
and see you have to support the show so
if you are wondering how to do that
here's the deal it's on the DC streaming
service they haven't said how much
that's gonna cost
it's basically DC's version of Netflix
like Disney has their own streaming
service that are developing that they're
gonna put all the Marvel all the Disney
all the Pixar stuff on so everybody has
their own version of that but they
haven't released a lot of information
about when it's coming out it'll
probably be cheaper than Netflix and
it's gonna have Titans so like you sign
up for you pay that monthly fee you get
a bunch of new shows including a new
Harley Quinn animated show but beyond
that they didn't clarify if they were
gonna do Terry McGinnis how they would
incorporate him because he's from the
future so they'd have to be some sort of
time-travel involved for Batman Beyond
to be Batman
during the events of Young Justice
season 3 or season 4 Stanley
so just stay tuned for that they'll
probably release a teaser or at least an
animatic in the next couple of months
they said they haven't finished
animating any of the episodes yet but
remember it takes about a year to get
animation out so they probably recorded
most of the dialogue with the actors
there are 26 episodes total so what I'm
expecting is is that they'll either
launch the series in the summer or
sometime in the fall but I'm expecting
it around the summer because that's what
a lot of animated series drop just
because most of their target audience
will be on break from school so they'll
have the free time to support the show
so just let me know in the comments
below which other characters beyond
Terry McGinnis do you want them to bring
on to Young Justice season 3 beyond the
ones that they've already announced and
there are a ton of characters since it's
the holidays be sure to leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below but congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last video
Robert Ricardo please private message me
so I can get your contact details I'll
name a new winner when I post new flash
click here for all my Wally West Titans
Easter eggs and because it's Stan Lee's
birthday click here to watch every
single one of his movie cameos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight